when check carmaker Tata rolled out the
t87 in 1936 it was the avant-garde of
automotive design it embodied the new
vehicular philosophy of the already
well-established company the steel body
was self-supporting and aerodynamic the
engine was air-cooled and rear mounted
at a time when most cars still looked
more like coaches the t87 triggered an
automotive revolution
tatra collector ohmic HUD SEC recalls
the first time he ever saw a t87 it was
not far from the former Tantra plant his
father was the founder of the German
Tantra Club every year before the season
began they would drive to the plant in
copra Nitze they took the opportunity to
look over the cars to Club their own
walked into an old barn and the first
thing he saw was the rear of a t87 he
didn't know what it was but he said to
himself I've got to have this car
something was already shot me so in
15-year techniques artisanal Dumas here
the progressive design was the work of
Han sled Vidya and Eric melaka that
vinegar was an austrian engineer and a
brilliant designer who had worked for
tantra since 1921
let vanka's credo was lightweight
construction an aerodynamic design it
broke with all the automotive
conventions of the time now it looks a
bit like something from the 1930 science
fiction series spats over the rear
wheels and the long sloping rear were an
early attempt at streamlining
the striking finding the back helped to
stabilize the car at high speeds
large air intakes kept the wind flowing
over the engine and back with the hot
air escaping through slits in the rear
lid
but it took a bit of practice to get
used to handling this rear heavy car
especially on wet pavement or at high
speeds driving expertise was essential
but we flat set confirms that the t87
fishtails all too easily and
unexpectedly there's no warning of any
kind the car may be speeding along at a
good clip and all of a sudden off it
goes the conus is the t87 spore weight
distribution
the two and a half liter rear mounted
engine had a light magnesium alloy block
but still it's lay heavy on the rear
axle the v-8 overhead cam was common
among racing and high-performance cars
of the time even with an output of just
75 horsepower at the aerodynamic t87
still reached top speeds close to 150
kilometers per hour
in contrast to the body the interior
appeared quite conventional aside from a
few art deco touches even with such a
complete array of instruments that
Tantra was easy to operate
the sightlines were generous through the
big windshields as long as the driver
was looking straight ahead
another feature unusual for the 1930s
was the manual sliding roof
the trunk in front carried two spare
wheels good to have along given the bad
roads of the time
the tatra t87 was high and avant-garde
so much so that only 3000 were ever
built
surviving communism the tantra company
produced cars until 1998 with
rear-mounted v8 engines to the very end